bonjour patrick jane bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin et
antonier sur notre sur notre chaîne un
mot d'abord sur la situation des sapeurs
pompiers on n'en parle pas beaucoup on
parle beaucoup des des policiers en ce
moment avec le bobo de la sécurité qui
reprend ce matin et la marche après
demain quelle est votre situation vous
êtes vous aussi on l'avait vu d'ailleurs
le premier mais aussi ciblé par par ces
violences
alors les sapeurs-pompiers sont
aujourd'hui une certaine façon de la
troisième force de sécurité intérieure
qui vient secourir qui vient est d
apporter des secours des soins aux
personnes et pas uniquement éteindre
l'incendié vous le savez plus de 80% de
nos missions aujourd'hui sont des
missions de secours est maintenant de
soins d'une rupture d'une chanson
personnes alors oui nous sommes des
sapeurs pompiers très sollicité et c'est
pour ça qu'un député fabien matras a
déposé une proposition de loi qui est
actuellement à l'étude
l'assemblée nationale est qui et qui
vise à favoriser et à consolider notre
modèle de sécurité civile
favoriser l'engagement de sapeurs
pompiers volontaires notamment mais
aussi vous venez de dire justement mais
aussi à promouvoir l'utilisation du
numéro 112 kg numéro européen d'urgence
qui existe depuis plus de 30 ans qui est
qui existe parce qu'il a été
la liste est institué dans un an dans un
règlement européen mais qui chez nous en
france et est peu mis en avant et
surtout qui équipe coordonnée entre
entre les différents acteurs entre les
policiers les gendarmes et les
sapeurs-pompiers et les samu qui qui
distribue des secours des soins de
l'assistance est une réponse à toutes
les situations d'urgence c'est ce numéro
unique s'avoue simplifierait la tâche au
quotidien
bah vous savez aujourd'hui le 112 est
répandu en france
dans la plupart des départements c'est
des sapeurs pompiers qui décroche le 112
parfois c'est un samuel qui décroche le
son 12 mais surtout dans la plupart des
départements ce sont des centres communs
qui sont disjoints ça veut dire qu'ils
sont un endroit différent et nous ce
qu'on voudrait ce que ce que la
fédération de sapeurs pompiers de france
se souhaite c'est de voir ces 112 dans
un même lieu dans chaque département qui
est un lieu commun pour répondre aux
appels pour coordonner les réponses
chacun fait son métier mais au même
endroit pourquoi parce que en fait nos
métiers sont sont très interconnecté
c'est à dire
et que quand les sapeurs pompiers
interviennent il ya parfois besoin de la
police de la gendarmerie a très souvent
un lien qui est fait avec le samu quand
samu reçoit un appel très très souvent
ils viennent demander l'intervention des
sapeurs pompiers
et tout ça autour d'un même numéro et
tout ça au même endroit fera quelque
chose de mieux coordonner de plus
efficace et chacun fera son métier dans
de meilleures conditions
le projet de loi préconise aussi une
bonification dans le calcul des
retraites des sapeurs pompiers qui je le
rappelle 180% et bénévoles il y à il ya
une crise de vocations alors que 80%
effectivement des sapeurs pompiers sont
volontaires
c'est à dire qu'ils sont indemnisés mais
mais mais ce n'est pas leur métier ils
ont un autre métier ou une autre
activité est effectivement le sujet de
valoriser 7,7 ce volontariat et de
fidéliser cet engagement c'est à dire de
faire en sorte que qui est une
incitation à rester plus longtemps au
service de la collectivité chez les
sapeurs pompiers est un vieux sujet qui
est portée effectivement par cette
proposition d'une crise de vocation à ce
que les volontaires sont toujours aussi
nombreux ou pas dans ces temps
difficiles alors les volontaires sont
nombreux mais il ya une tendance ce qui
restent moins longtemps vous savez quand
quand l'exercice est difficile quand
vous êtes effectivement de temps en
temps le lait la cible d'actions venant
que vous pouvez décourager donc on a
sinon une crise des vocations en tout
cas une crise de la permanence de cet
engagement
on a des engagements qui sont plus
courts qu'auparavant et on souhaite
faire en sorte que le sapeur pompier
volontaire qui s'engagent trouve les
meilleures conditions pour porter
secours
ses concitoyens pour pour porter de
l'assistance et ne soit pas décourager
par diverses difficultés qu'ils peuvent
rencontrer vous lisiez il ya de plus en
plus d'interventions pour au secours à
la personne comment est-ce que vous
l'expliquer est-ce que c'est là est la
crise sanitaire doublée d'une crise
sécuritaire qu'on constate en ce moment
alors ça n'a pas attendu la crise
sanitaire
mais depuis depuis 30 ans chaque année
les sapeurs pompiers font un petit peu
plus de tout secours d'urgence aux
personnes
pourquoi parce que premièrement il ya
des acteurs de santé qui ont presque
disparu en trouvent plus difficilement
qu'auparavant par exemple
garde sans doute également la population
est plus exigeante et puis effectivement
la crise de kobe de la montrer que ce
soit pendant la première phase du sapeur
pompier ont apporté un concours très
précieux la première réponse lorsque
ensuite il est venu le temps des tests
et maintenant les vaccinations
aujourd'hui partout en france les
sapeurs-pompiers armes des centres de
vaccination et vaccine chaque jour des
centaines de milliers de personnes
les sapeurs-pompiers sont plus
uniquement les soldats du feu sont
également les soldats de la vie c'est
pas récent mais la crise du peu vite l'a
très bien montré
oui on a vu aussi que faisait l'objet de
violences est ce que vous diriez vous
connaissez bien terrain est ce que vous
partagez le constat des militaires de
sentinelle notamment qui patrouillent
partout en france et celle des policiers
qui alerte le gouvernement aujourd'hui
quel est votre constat goût de la
situation sécuritaire
c'est un constat que chacun fait
évidemment le on nous sommes dans une
société qui tend d'une société qui est
volontiers violente c'est pas très
nouveau mais c'est quelque chose qui
s'accroît je pense que chacun en est
conscient et la remontée des
informations qui nous remontent et
quotidienne d'information suffit
largement à alerter les pouvoirs publics
qui est qu'ils en sont conscients gens
sont tout à fait conscients de la
difficulté est naturellement de la
nature de la réponse à apporter
mais je crois que chacun en est
conscient le fait d'augmenter les peines
justement encourus pour agression de
policiers est ce que ça ça pourrait être
adapter aussi à votre profession alors
ce que la fédération a demandé c'est que
le régime qui est applicable le régime
d'aggravation des peines qui est
applicable aux forces de sécurité
intérieure le soit également pour les
sapeurs pompiers qui je le répète sur la
troisième force de sécurité intérieure
qui est pas une force de sécurité
publique mais une force de sécurité
civile donc ce régime d'aggravation des
peines soit applicable
cela étant vous savez une réponse face à
des actes de violence s'est pas
uniquement les peines encourues
c'est un ensemble de facteurs c'est de
la prévention c'est la réalité des
peines prononcées la réalité des peines
exécutées
et puis surtout ce sentiment que quoi
qu'il arrive si vous êtes violent vous
serez vous serez condamné pas forcément
une peine très grave vous savez ça fait
depuis plusieurs siècles que ça a été
montré il vaut mieux être certain
d'avoir un châtiment peut-être modéré
plutôt que l'illusion à laquelle on
essaiera d'échappée de châtiment
terrible en fait qu'il n'arrive jamais
voilà c'est pas le quantum de la peine
qui est le plus important c'est le fait
que oui c'est la dissuasion et et que
personne n'a de médecins voilà c'est ce
qu'on a pu appeler la tolérance zéro
c'est la politique aujourd'hui de des
services d'incendié et de secours c'est
qu'on signale tous les faits de violence
et qu'on engage des poursuites pour tous
les faits de violence merci beaucoup
patrick jane de nous avoir livré votre
témoignage en direct ce matin sur la pré
france merci